on va faire vous êtes prêts rené leveret
moi je suis prête la mairie cus vois pas
où je n'y vois pas ce que je lis pas
bouger bouger
j'écris la réponse au 10
rue dit rudy tout en la tournant
toujours intéressé vous êtes concentré
llodra reste là bas je ne peux pas pas
amis ou aller à l'eau alors allez y
messieurs enfin
20 /
2009 douceur égal
bravo bravo
les gars vous êtes ici fait le chien
devient papa
oui bon allez on n'a rien fait dit
montre moins ça mérite ou le toit
attention à 6 attention il ya du moins
ne t'inquiète pas jamais on est un peu
allez russe n'a pas bougé pour la galice
ou pouxviel et -8 m'arrangerait on
me demande de jouer j'adore je termine
attention attention bombay avoir essayé
vas-y
/ toi - tweet +2 égal à temps égal
bonnes réponses
ça fait 10 moins vite fait de plus de 4
[Applaudissements]
et 6 ans
qu'est-ce qu'il est bien branché à
donner une tonne de coke est
alors allé
à tanger attention alors déjà mais
c'est tout le vécu des drames et pas
bougé alors michel à les hisser notre
alors attendez
/ cs4 +3 égal attendez vous pouvez leur
faire
crédit elle nous a coupé
25 / 5 - 4 + 3 et galeux
oui
c'est papa chéri n'est ni budden
attention si lady reste concentré
je m'amuse je comprends d'être choqués
des battues par la cnops
s'est pas non plus rassuré demi cent
cinquante mille
ainsi si vous dire papa tient le feu
à bouger magali 12 / 4 + 3 - 2 eagle
[Applaudissements]
régalez vous concentrez vous allez trop
vite c'est pas de ma faute il va plus
vite que
c'est tout a redit c'est la dernière
rudy c'est l'anarchie ces derniers
attention avez un afin que tu peux mais
c'est gagner on a l'air un peu
intelligent tu sera difficile
et derrière +6 points attention
attention à ses 16 ans je sois gamin
c'est beaucoup voilà beaucoup mieux que
ça arrive pas alors
par 4.6 white eagle
ouais c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
vous avez parlé canada
on
peut venir et dire
[Applaudissements]